This is one of those instances where you
canSit here and style a project forever and
get it to look exactly the way you want.
But for now I just want to go over some of
the things we covered in today's lesson
First we started off with individual
variables for all this and then
We decided to actually create an object out
of those which will work a lot
better and make reusable code a lot easier
so when I want to actually
Change individual properties it changes for
all of them
We want to talk too much about this page
though that's just a little bit of extra
fluffI guess I shouldn't say that.
So we just did the page load and I won't go
too ended up with that that's just like a
little extra
Showing off if you will to just add
different functionality to your website if
you want
The big thing is we refactored our functions
for our attack
If you remember originally we had a single
attack function that did both the hero
attack the villain attack and it also drew
the health
And we actually refactor those into their
own separate functions
That increases readability and reusability
for if I ever want to actually call in that
hero attack maybe the hero attacks
when he gets critical hit if there's a
critical hit I can actually make my hero
respond and attack once more
And if I wanted that all at that point I
needed to do is actually call this function
into wherever that needs to go
We also went over some simple conditions
here so we just render these alerts whenever
the health is at or below zero and we did
the same thing for the villain this is just
going over how to use our conditionals and
how to actually pass these arguments within
them
We showed off using the math-up floor mat
that random to get a random generate
number for in this instance it's going to be
a number that's 0 through 10
We also sold this ifIf true then render the.
Return that's after it so we'll sayIf above.
If this is true.
Return this
So it's a little bit simpler than using a
ternary because a ternary would be
a bad use case here since I'm not returning
anything if it's actually falseSo I can just
make this if.
If true statement here return this alert
We also showed off making this variable hero
attack like I said and reducing the hero's
Health every time this is clicked
And the functionality for the villain attack
is going to be essentially the same we just
do some also checksTo make sure we're.
If the health is below zero on either one of
these that we're not going to allow that to
happen we're just going to return
immediately
After that we had our draw hero health and I
just want to go over making sure we got
these hero Health eels
And we go to our Dom and get that Ellen by
its ID that we
put on our index at HTML and we use this
ternary to set the health
To the hero Health if the health is above
zero but if that's false we said to these
three cost bones
And also showed off this cool way to add a
class
Whenever his health is actually at or below
zero
Then we worked on our health whichWe just
passed through both our draw hero health and
villain health.
And then we also did our drink potion
Which we made this if else statement here so
we kind of go from the top so obviously if
we don't have a potion we're going to alert
that
we don't if our health is already above 100
we can't drink a potion and if her health is
at or below zero we can't drink a potion
either
And then off all those are false we can go
ahead and actually set our time out to 3
secondsTo actually run this health up.
Which then increase our health by 25
And lastly we made this kind of this custom
function for that role for health potion
And we reuse our math up floor mat that Ram
to get a random number between 1 and 10
And then if that number is above 8 we can go
ahead and flip that bull
on our object to true and that allows us to
actually use that health potion
I hope you enjoyed this lecture I know it's
a little bit if you're a gamer like me it's
cool seeing
the implementation of actually making these
games come to life and always feel free to
add like I said any little
extra things you want to add to your project
you can make it more complicated if you want
make it
Less complicated if you're not super into
games as well
Because I do know this is a topic that
sometimes people who aren't Gamers struggle
with is that gamer logic
Sometimes the best thing is just to keep it
simple and don't overcomplicate it
But thank you for following along and that
will be our intro to JavaScript lectureThank
you.